うん
いいなぁ
ヤスコさんのウクレレ
映画って言われるんです
ウクレレやってましたよね
あーもうやってないの
もうやってないんですか
そうか
なんかどうしたか
じゃあ中国語の先生とそれからウクレレの先生と
お二人同士にお辞めになっちゃったんですけど
一人もお亡くなりになっちゃったの
うんうんうん
それでなんかだから両方やってて
ちょうどいいものをね
選んだって妹なんか言ってたんだけど
急に両方やらなくなっちゃった
あ、それは残念
でも中国語は
時々
辞書見て文章作ってました
中国人のね
お友達の神父様がいるの
あ、そうなんですか
はい
とってもいい
あ、やっぱいられるぞ
すごくかわいしい
昔
あ、フランシス
フランシス
チャペルの主任主題が
中国人
前
今は
えっと
中道院で
セタ
だから全然
あえんな
今は、中道院で教えていたんだ。
だから、全然あいつもあいつも。
ヤスコさん、ウクレレ習ってたの知ってる?
知る。
今、先生がちょうどいらっしゃらなくなった。
それは、こうなんて、だからまた先生。
他のこと、スペイン語とかだとね、少しやって、なんかちょっと言えるじゃない。
どこそこ行きました、ぐらいだけ。
中高だと言えないのよ、そのくらいの簡単な言葉。
習ってたんですか?生学校?
生学校?生学校で習ってた?
クラスに入ってたのよ、ちゃんと。
何年ぐらい?
何ぐらいだったの?
8年ぐらいかな。初め10年ぐらいだったんだけど、すぐ8年ぐらいになって。
何年間で、どこそ行くか。
うちのもやるなかったんだ。
だから、そうがないよね。
そうがないよね。
そうがない。
うん。
そうやった。